[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts the sorting hat the
house system gryffindor southern
ravenclaw hufflepuff and the cast
members of harry potter now at this
stage we must all know the houses of our
favorite harry potter characters like
draco in slytherin hermione and
gryffindor and so on and so forth and if
you don't know well i don't know what
franchise you've been watching however
what i want to explore today are the
houses of the respective actors that
played these iconic roles harry potter
is played by daniel radcliffe is he a
gryffindor is tom felton played by draco
actually a slytherin how do their real
personalities line up with their
on-screen personalities are there any
discrepancies is anyone just like their
character
well today we're going to be looking at
15 cast members and answering these very
questions let me also preface this video
by saying that these 15 actors have
either confirmed through interviews and
or social media that they're in the
house i've mentioned or it's been
confirmed through pottermore no
porcupines here and before we dive in
let me just quickly remind you of some
of the defining traits associated with
each house
this is best explained in the words of
the sorting hat
by gryffindor the bravest were prized
far beyond the rest for ravenclaw the
cleverest would always be the best for
hufflepuff hard workers were most worthy
of admission and power-hungry slytherin
loved those of great ambition anyway
let's get started number one harry
potter daniel radcliffe kicking things
off in spectacular fashion we're going
to start with the character that the
story is centered around our very own
harry potter harry is of course played
by actor daniel radcliffe and it just so
happens that radcliffe eliminated
confusion surrounding his actual house
in a 2014 reddit ama where he said the
following to me i absolutely think i
would be in gryffindor but there's never
any doubt of that for me yeah i like
maybe i'm just biased because i played
one for so long but i could never
picture myself in any other colors it
makes sense that radcliffe and harry
sort of melded into one particularly
given the duration of the role however i
will also say this there is plenty of
early onset behind the scenes footage
available for the harry potter films and
daniel always seemed to be up to
something perhaps daniel at least in his
earlier years was more of a slytherin
maybe the sorting hat's analysis on
harry could very well be applicable to
daniel as well
2. ron weasley rupert grint ron weasley
who played harry's best friend and later
hermione's husband was played by the one
and only rupert grint grint who plays a
gryffindor in the series actually took
the pottermore quiz in 2016 expressing
that it was very in-depth and as it
turns out rupert is in fact a hufflepuff
not a gryffindor he had this to say oh
yeah no i feel pretty good he said it
wasn't what i was expecting but that's
really clever yeah i love that and i
don't know about you guys but i always
felt like ron sort of skirted on the
line between hufflepuff and gryffindor
so perhaps this was just another example
of grint's perfect casting
number three dean thomas alfred enoch
when the official wizarding world
twitter issued a sorting challenge in
late 2021 alfred enoch who played dean
thomas was one of the first to dive in
and as it turns out alfred much like the
character he plays is a gryffindor he
had this to say of his sorting
something that fills me with a nice warm
glow i'd always imagined i'd be
gryffindor as a kid so it was nice to
have that confirmed 4. nymphadora tonks
natalia tina unsurprisingly alfred enoch
wasn't the only actor to participate in
the late 2021 sorting challenge as
actress natalia tina who plays
nymphadora tonks also revealed which
hogwarts house she belongs to nymphodora
who usually just goes by tonks was a
proud hufflepuff in the harry potter
series and as it turns out tina is also
a hufflepuff after finding out the
result tina celebrated her house by
saying we are badgers and loyal and
hardworking number five flitwick warwick
davis warwick davis plays professor
phillius flipwick in the harry potter
films also less notably griphook
flipwick's character was known for many
things his mastery of dueling his
teaching of charms and perhaps most
notably being the head of ravenclaw
house alongside tina and enoch davis
also ended up being sorted during the
2021 sorting challenge revealing that he
too had been placed into the same house
as his character davis was a ravenclaw
perhaps the casting for harry potter was
even better than we previously thought
6. bellatrix estranged helena bonham
carter bellatrix lestrange voldemort's
infamous right-hand woman was expertly
played by actress helena bonham carter
based on the insanity of her character
one might assume that it would require
an actress who at least loosely
resembled this character and though many
on this list ended up being sorted into
the same house the same certainly cannot
be said for carter who was sorted into
hufflepuff house in fact core aspects of
hufflepuff house like being loyal and
true are entirely befitting of carter 7.
minerva mcgonagall maggie smith though
maggie smith who plays minerva
mcgonagall has fairly openly expressed
her disinterest in discussing the harry
potter series in more recent years we do
fortunately have some idea of the house
she'd belong to and that's because her
downton abbey co-star laura carmichael
revealed in an interview that violet
maggie would have to be gryffindor this
isn't proof of her house but it does
give us some idea 8. draco malfoy tom
felton in the harry potter films tom
felton plays draco malfoy a cruel
prejudiced cunning sudderin and harry's
tormentor however as it turns out felton
couldn't be any more different than his
theatrical counterpart in a 2015 tweet
he said the following today was the day
i finally did it i joined pottermore and
was sorted into
gryffindor heartbroken
southern for life however that wasn't
the end of felton's sorting story as
later he took the sorting quiz once
again revealing that he's now a
hufflepuff he captioned his instagram
post a sad day on so many levels
harry potter at home
9. neville longbottom matthew lewis
actor matthew lewis played the
mild-natured and later exceedingly
courageous neville longbottom a proud
gryffindor he was a gryffindor through
and through even going on to wield the
sword of gryffindor however as it turns
out lewis is a hufflepuff in 2016 he
took the pottermore test on camera and
said the following i got hufflepuff and
i'm thrilled
he deadpans no i am i'm really happy
with hufflepuff of course i am excellent
that's cool wicked 10. ginny weasley
bonnie right ginny weasley harry's love
interest and the sister of his best
friend ron is played by bonnie wright in
2016 alongside several other cast
members she did her pottermore house
test on camera guys i'm a gryffindor
said bonnie right i feel very relieved i
feel proud can't say i'm surprised there
11. luna lovegood ivana lynch actress
ivana lynch plays luna lovegood the
eccentric ravenclaw student who is known
for peculiar behavior in 2016 lynch had
her own house results revealed on camera
which prompted her to shout in
excitement gryffindor lynch also added
that she was thrilled but also like not
surprised 12. hermione granger emma
watson hermione granger harry's trusty
friend and ron's later love interest is
played by none other than emma watson in
the past watson has shared her opinion
on which houses she believes the
hamilton cast members would belong to
however she herself has never revealed
her own house with that said watson did
make a post on instagram in late 2021
where she revealed that her character
hermione was her favorite fictional
character of all time
maybe that's because emma sees so much
of herself in her character if i had to
guess i would definitely say she's a
gryffindor 13. weasley twins james and
oliver phelps the mischievous weasley
twins fred and george weasley were
played respectively by actors james and
oliver phelps in the story the pair are
both gryffindors sharing a house but in
real life that's not the case in a 2020
interview for wizarding world james
revealed that he was in fact a
hufflepuff adding which is cool but even
cooler as i actually have a badger
living under my shed where oliver
remained a gryffindor just like his
character remarking i was putting
gryffindor which i was very happy with
it helps when you already have the
uniform 14. severus snape alan rickman
severus snape head of slytherin house
was expertly played by the late alan
rickman
rickman's performance as snape was one
of the best in the series particularly
as rickman was so very much unlike his
character i found a few sources
expressing that rickman had in fact been
sorted into ravenclaw house behind the
scenes but i'm not sure they're credible
enough to completely go by i thought i'd
leave this one up to you guys which
house do you think the late and great
alan rickman belonged to comment below
15. jk rowling jk rowling was
responsible for writing harry potter the
series that we all know and love so much
she created hogwarts the four houses and
the sorting hat so i for one was
exceedingly curious about which house
she belonged to as it turns out during a
harry potter web chat many years ago
rowling revealed that she was in fact a
gryffindor i logged on i'm now on
pottermore as a regular user that's how
i check what's going on even though i'm
not going to give my username i won't do
the sorting i had a moment i thought hey
i'm not sure if i answered the questions
i answered honestly to get me into
gryffindor but yes i am in gryffindor
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think of these sortings do you find
it interesting that most of the actors
were sorted into the houses of
characters they played is that
coincidence if you want me to theorize
on the houses of some of the other
actors in another video then leave a
comment down below until next time
remember happiness can be found even in
the darkest of times if one only
remembers to turn on the light